let's go back to 1957 representatives
from six European countries had come to
Rome to sign the treaty that were to
create the European Union Europe was
destroyed a world war had emerged from
Europe the human suffering was
unbelievable and unprecedented those men
wanted to create a peaceful democratic
Europe a Europe that works for its
people and one of the many building
blocks in that peace project was a
common European market already back then
they saw how markets when left to
themselves can sort of slip into being
just the private property of big
businesses and cartels meeting the needs
of some businesses and not the needs of
customers so from our very first day in
1957 the European Union had rules to
defend fair competition and that means
competition on the merits that you
compete on the quality of your products
the prizes you can offer the services
the innovation that you produce that's
competition on the merits you have a
fair chance of making it in such a
market and it's my job as commissioner
for a competition to make sure that
companies who do business in Europe live
by those rules
but let's take a step back why why do we
need rules on competition at all why not
just let businesses compete is that also
the best for us if they compete freely
since more competition drives more
quality lower prices more innovation
well mostly it is but the problem is
that sometimes for businesses
competition can be inconvenient because
competition means that the race is never
over the game is never won no matter how
well you were doing in the past there's
always someone who are out there wanting
to take your place so the temptation to
avoid competition is powerful it's
rooted in motives as old as Adam and Eve
in greed for yet more money in fear of
losing your position in the market and
all the benefits it brings and when
greed and fear are linked to power you
have a dangerous mix we see that in
political life in part of the world the
mix of of greed and fear means that
those who get power becomes reluctant to
give it back one of the many things I I
like and admire in our democracies other
norms that make our leaders hand over
power when voters tell them to and
competition rules can do a similar thing
in the market making sure that greed and
fear doesn't overcome
because those rules mean that companies
cannot misuse their power to undermine
competition think for a moment about
your car it has thousands of parts from
the foam that makes the seats to the
electrical wiring to the light balls and
for many of those parts the world's car
makers they are dependent on only few
suppliers so it's hardly surprising that
it is kind of tempting for those
suppliers to come together and fix
prices but just imagine what that could
do to the final price of your new car in
the market except it's not imaginary
the European Commission has dealt with
already seven different car parts
cartels and we're still investigating
some here the Department of Justice are
also looking into the market for car
parts and it has called it the biggest
criminal investigation it has ever
pursued but without competition rules
there would be no investigation and
there would be nothing from stop this
collusion from happening and the prices
of your car to go up yet it's not only
companies who can undermine fair
competition governments can do it too
and governments do that when they hand
out subsidies to just the favorite view
the selected they may do that when they
hand out subsidies and of course all
financed by tax payers to companies that
may be in the form of special tax
treatments like the tax benefits that
firms like fear
Starbucks and Apple got from some
governments in Europe though subsidies
stopped companies from competing on
equal terms they can mean that the
companies that succeed well they are the
companies that got the most subsidy the
ones that are the best connected and not
as it should be the companies that
serves consumers the best so there are
times when we need to step in to make
sure that competition works
the way it should by doing that we help
the market to work fairly because
competition give consumers the power to
demand a fair deal it means that
companies know that if they cannot offer
good prices or the service that's
expected well the customers will go
somewhere else and that sort of fan is
is more important that we may sometimes
realize very few people think about
politics all the time
some even skip it at election time but
we are all in the markets every day
we're in the market and we don't want
businesses to agree on prizes in the
back office we don't want them to divide
the market between them we don't want
one big company just to shut out
competitors from ever showing us what
they can do if that happens well
obviously we feel that someone has
cheated us that we are being ignored or
taken for granted by the market and that
may undermine not only our trust in the
market but also in the trust in the
society in a recent survey more than
two-thirds of Europeans said that they
had felt the lack the effects of lack of
competition that the price for
electricity was too high
that the price for the medicines they
needed was too high that they had no
real choice if they wanted to travel by
bus or by plane
oh they got poor service from their
internet provider in short they found
that the market didn't treat them fairly
and those that might seem as there are
small things but they can give you this
sense that the world isn't really fair
and they see the market which were
supposed to serve everyone becomes more
like the private property of a few
powerful companies the market is not the
society our societies of course much
much more than the market but lack of
trust in the markets can rub off on
society so we lose trust in our society
as well and it may be the most important
thing we have trust we can trust each
other if we are treated as equals if we
are all to have the same chances well we
all have to follow the same fundamental
rules of course some people and some
businesses are more successful than
others but we do not trust in a society
if the prizes are handed out even before
the contest begin and this is where
competition rules comes in because when
we make sure that markets work fairly
then businesses compete on the merits
and that helps to build the trust that
we need as citizens to feel comfortable
and in control and the trust that allows
our society to work because without
trust everything becomes harder just to
live our daily lives we need to trust in
strangers
to stress the banks who keeps our money
the builders who build our home the
electrician who comes to fix the wiring
the doctor who treated when we're ill
not to mention the other drivers on the
road and in the one no they are crazy
and yet we have to trust them to do the
right thing and the thing is that the
more our societies grow the more
important trust becomes and the harder
it is to build and that is a paradox of
modern societies and this is especially
through when technology changes the way
that we interact of course to some
degree technology can help us to build
trust in one another with with rating
system and other system that enables a
sharing economy but technology also
create create completely new challenges
when they ask us not to trust in other
people but to trust in algorithms and
computers of course we all see and share
and appreciate all the goods that new
technology can do us it's a lot of good
autonomous cars can give people with
disabilities new independence it can
save us all time and it can make a much
much better use of resources algorithms
that rely on crunches crunching enormous
amounts of data can enable our doctors
to give us a much better treatment and
many other things but no one is going to
hand over their medical data or to step
into a car that's driven by an algorithm
unless they trust the companies that
they are dealing with and that Trust
isn't always there today for example
less than a quarter of European trusts
online businesses
to protect their personal information
but what if people knew that they could
rely on technology companies to treat
them fairly
what if they knew that those companies
respond to a competition by trying to do
better by trying to serve consumers
better not by using their power to shut
out competitors say by pushing their
services far far down the list of search
results and promoting themselves what if
they knew that compliance with the rules
was built into the algorithms by this
design that the algorithms had to go to
competition rule school before they were
ever allowed to work that those
algorithms was designed in a way that
meant that they couldn't knut that they
couldn't form their own little Carter in
the black box they're working in
together with regulation competition
rules can do that they can help us to
make sure that new technology treats
people fairly and that everyone can
compete on a level playing field and
that can help us build the trust that we
need for real innovation to flourish and
for societies to develop for citizens
because Trust cannot be imposed it has
to be earned since the very first days
of the European Union 60 years ago our
competition rules have helped to build
that trust a lot of things have changed
it's hard to say what those six
representatives would have made of a
smartphone but in today's world as well
as in their world
competition make the market work for
everyone and that is why I am convinced
that real and fair competition has a
vital role to play in building the trust
we need to get the best of our societies
and that starting with enforcing our
rules actually just to make the market
work for everyone thank you thank you
Thank You commissioner I want to ask you
two questions the first one is about
data because every impression the
technology and data are changing the way
competition takes place and the way
computational regulation is designed and
enforced can you maybe comment on that
well yes it is it's definitely
challenging us because we we both have
to sharpen our tools but also to develop
new tools when we were going through the
the Google responses to our statement of
objection we were going through 5.2
terabytes of data if it's quite a lot so
so we had to set up new systems we had
to figure out how to do this because you
cannot work the way you did just a few
years ago so we're definitely sharpening
up our working methods the other thing
is that we try to distinguish between
different kind of data because some data
is extremely valuable and they will form
like a barrier to entry in the markets
other things you can just it loses a
value tomorrow so we try to make sure
that we never ever underestimate the
fact that data works as a currency in
the market and as an asset that can be a
real barrier for competition Google you
find them 2.8 billion euros a few months
ago
no that was dollar it's not so strong
these days well it depends on the on the
google appeal the case the case is going
to court will last a while earlier last
year you asked Apple to pay 13 billion
in back taxes and and you have also
investigated other companies including
European and Russian companies not only
American companies by far yet the the
the investigations against the American
companies are the ones that have
attracted most attention and the also
tracked is some acquisitions we've been
accused the century of protectionism of
jealousy or using legislation to eat
back at American companies that have
conquered the European markets The
Economist just this week on the front
page writes
the Steyr versus the valley how do you
react to that well first of all I take
it very serious because bias has no room
in law enforcement we have to prove our
cases with the evidence and the facts
and the and the jurisprudence in order
also to present it to the courts and the
second thing is that Europe is open for
business but not for tax evasion what
you think is that that we're changing
and firstly when I ask my daughter's
they use Google as well why do you do
that they say well because it works it's
a very good product they would never
ever come up with the answer it's
because it's a u.s. product it's just
because it works and that is of course
how it should be but just the same it is
important that someone is looking after
to say well we congratulate you while
you grow and grow and grow but
congratulations stops if we find that
you're misusing your position to harm
competitors so that they cannot serve
consumers and be a fascinating case to
follow thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]